[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
So my guest today
is Joe Born, co-founder of the
startup behind the Hale Dreamer
Alarm Clock.
Thanks for coming
on the show today.
JOE BORN: Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: So this
is a hardware product.
You worked in hardware.
How has crowdfunding changed
hardware, do you think?
JOE BORN: Oh, night and day.
You are talking about we
suddenly have the ability
to release a product and get
market feedback before we've
actually brought it
into full production.
It's a much more
important factor
than many of the others that
get more notoriety-- 3D printing
and some of the
open source stuff--
because you think
about the ability
to get feedback up front without
making these big investments.
That's really changed.
It's really turned
hardware development
upside down-- very big impact
MARTIN OMANDER: And you
used it to your advantage
for building this product.
Could you tell us a
bit more about that?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
So our goal was a little bit
unconventional in this product.
So we really wanted to
get up-front feedback
and really see particularly
developer, early adopter
community with our product.
So for example, the hardware's
got a relatively open
interface.
And that allowed us to
recruit a few other apps that
would work with our hardware
as a result of Android Central
and some of the publicity
that we got out of the gate.
And that came from that
very focused approach
that, in this case,
crowdfunding facilitated.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
So for you, it was just as much
crowd marketing and building
community as getting the
funding for the product.
JOE BORN: Yeah, that's right.
And so Kickstarter is
a big, big community
of very involved users
that it's very hard
to get out of traditional kind
of mass distribution and sales
channels.
So whereas Amazon is very
mainstream or [INAUDIBLE]
or the like, Kickstarter
really does get you
that early adopter, that
very involved consumer.
And that's very important to
try and recruit them up front,
particularly with many
of the hardware devices.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mm, I see.
And crowdfunding runs
in the family, I hear.
Your daughter ran a campaign.
Could you tell us a
bit more about that?
JOE BORN: So my daughter's
going into seventh grade now.
And she invented a no-spill cup.
My dad has Parkinson's.
His hand tremors, and he
was shaking and spilling.
And so she invented
a three-legged cup
that holds the
base off the ground
and did a couple crowdfunding
campaigns, the most
recent over the summer.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
That must have been a
great learning experience
for both you and your daughter.
What did you learn?
What was unexpected?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
Well, one of the big
unexpected things
was-- and I think there's
a lesson for all of us--
that if you'd asked me
what's important for her
as an inventor coming
out of the gate,
I'd have said, well, aesthetic
sense and the ability
to iterate and stuff.
But it turns out that
being a spokesman
is really, in many ways,
much more important
than those details.
Because it was her ability to
articulate and tell the story
that really captivated
people and really recruited
interest and developed stuff.
So I think that's a good
part of what crowdfunding
does in forcing us to
articulate the product.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
You have that one-
or two-minute video,
and you have to pack
it all in there.
JOE BORN: Yeah.
And I think that's
a great exercise.
Because we start out, and
we and our co-founders
are so used to the product.
And they've heard the
articulation a million times,
and they get used
to the fact that it
has 10 million features.
All of a sudden,
now you're forced,
how do I articulate this at
a very high level to someone
who doesn't know the product
in a minute or two minutes?
And going through that
exercise is really
an important discipline--
what's important,
what's not important,
what could I leave off?
And I think going through
that exercise early really
is a help to
understanding your product
and how you're going
to sell it and how
you're going to articulate it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
A lot of people with
an engineering mindset,
like me, we start thinking about
a product and start building
it.
And feedback comes
way late, well after.
JOE BORN: And that's the
conventional way, right?
And that's why crowdfunding
is so important.
Because all of a sudden, we
find ourselves selling a product
before we've completed the
whole engineering process.
Well, that's great,
because now there's
plenty of time to make changes
and get feedback and learn
from it before you've
made all the investments
and before you've
locked yourself
into the technology, the
details, the implementation,
and so on and so forth.
So I think that kind
of exercise probably
is as good for
software as hardware.
But particularly so in
hardware where you do
have to make investments.
And a lot of those
investments do lock you
into certain things.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
Because it's harder
to change hardware,
you mean, than software?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
Hardware's become
more like software--
more iterative, more
software-driven.
But you still have a
physical manifestation
that's in the field and can't
be changed-- at least the knobs
and buttons and housing,
and that kind of stuff.
So you do get
locked into tooling,
and you have to make
decisions that do lock you in.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Great.
So how is your daughter's
campaign and product doing?
JOE BORN: Good.
We've sold 10,000 cups over
the summer, so $62,000 worth.
And now we're feverishly working
to bring those into production
and tool it up and
ship those to people.
It's called the Kangaroo
Cup, if any of your viewers
are interested.
MARTIN OMANDER: Kangaroo Cup.
Great.
Well, thank you so much for
coming on the show, Joe,
and sharing your experience, and
that of your daughter, with us.
Best of luck with your
product and your daughter's.
JOE BORN: Yes.
I'll pass that along.
Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time!